hello everyone and welcome to Game
twelve of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between my cattle and
Mikhail Botvinnik now a lot of you are
asking in comments that I should do more
this match and less of the other games
but I don't have to follow up on some
events that are currently happening in
the world and this isn't going anywhere
there are still a lot more games from
this match so you know the best not
rushed things that we should we should
savor these moments so for those of you
who have seen this the this series from
the start this is game 12th if you
remember in game 11 tall won a great one
a great victory with the white pieces
and if you also remember towel towel
towel already had a three lead point in
the match but he didn't really feel
confident then botanique won two games
in a row then towel really didn't feel
confident and now in the game 11 towel
managed to win he's once again 2 points
in the lead and now he's more confident
than ever to take botanique on with the
black pieces so this is a pretty much
we're now in the second half of the
match so in the first half Todd did
relatively well and now it's time to
continue the match and the towel says
that this is one of the games that most
commentators since since this game was
played in the books in the articles in
the newspapers they really like to use
these games to really point out the
mistakes that were made but Todd says
that this is normal I mean you you go
play against botanique an end play a
perfect game so let's see it but when it
once again opens with c4 we have Knight
to f6 d 4e 6/9 to f3 so once again the
ante name is oh and here Todd was for
the d5 he transposes into the Queens
gambit declined as he does know the
lines which watch many favors so he
feels relatively comfortable playing
this against him
we have Knight to c3 c5 and here Botany
plays III and III was kind of a kind of
a surprise for tall then what he decided
to go like this tall was of course
expecting C captors on d5 Knight
captures on d5 and only then III
as this is the variation both eunuch
played in in his famous game against
Alexander awaken in the very strong and
famous Avro tournament of 1938 I haven't
covered that game yet but I'm
considering about covering that
tournament entirely so I don't I don't
think I'll be doing just that game but I
did cover between his game against
capablanca from the strong Avro
tournament of 1938 I will put a link to
that game in the description below if
you want to check it out that's a very
nice game
so after c5 no seek a person be 5'4 tall
as botanique of course knows that this
game being so favors famous everyone
will be prepared for this line against
Botvinnik he goes the immediate III
Knight to c6 and now a3 Bishop to d6 and
now D captures on c5 here this is Bishop
to d6 tal uses this maneuver to pretty
much force Botvinnik to capture two
Tempe and in the end the towel is very
very well prepared for this so D
captures on c5 Bishop captures and now
before gaining momentum on the Queen
side Bishop to d6 and now Bishop to d2
Bishop to b2 tal castles C capture son b
5ek after sandy 5 and Mount nice to b5 a
pressuring that bishop on d6 and of
course I'm sure all of you do cy Knight
captures on d5 is no way to win a pawn
Knight captures Queen character sendin
Bishop to b4 check loses the Queen I
hope everyone saw that so after I
capture some default Knight to d5
attacking the bishop bishop to be 8 and
now Bishop to e2 here a5 and here you
can see that the tallest bishops are
very nicely eyeing that eyeing that
Queen side and the way to the move a5 he
actually wants to get his a a8 rook into
the game he wants to get it into the
game either by playing a capture some
before either by forcing both eunuchs to
play B captors on a5 botanique plays big
actors on a5 and top plays Knight
captures an f5 & Botvinnik is relatively
satisfied here at this Knight is poorly
placed on the on the edge of the board
but this is actually what it all wanted
now tall has this rook to a6 a beautiful
rope lift and then from a six the rook
can come into the game ivi rook to g6 or
rook to h6 depending on the position so
botany castle and here we have rook to a
six-dollar continues with his plan and
here Bishop to e5 Bishop to e5 tall
really likes this move by what Phoenix
not because it all agrees that is the
strongest move in the position but it
also really complements about Phoenix
style of play he says that Knight B to
d4 is also an idea but after rook to b6
attacking the bishop bishop moves Knight
to c4 and Queen to c2
it is perfectly fine here but all of the
pieces are still on the board and the
black does have a bit more activity here
so Bishop to e5 but when he wants to
exchange this piece Bishop captures
Knight captures and now rook to e8
attacking the knight Knight back to b3
we have Knight to e4 and this Knight -
if Knight to e4 is pretty pretty
aggressive move actually now towel is
preparing the rook to g6 maybe rook to
h6 maybe this rook can come to e5 nine
for me five he can come to g5 so a lot
of ideas for tiles rooks here and here
comes a move by Botvinnik
and this is my favorite move of the of
the entire game because it's really it's
really a complicated move and it's
really a powerful move it's like the
best move you can play in this position
it's the engines favorite and it's what
Botvinnik plays but first I will show
you why why it's why it's not an easy
move to play but when it played Knight
to f4 his idea is as he does have told
us have an isolated pawn here so what we
call now organized play against this
isolated pawn and you know perhaps try
to even capture it why not but this is
something that tall decided to use
against botany as tall tall knows that
what eunuch really enjoys playing with
best with isolated points and the gasp
and again against best bones and the
botany is like a master of playing
positions where he's the one having an
isolated bone
so ii thought that if he chooses a
variation where he has an isolated
wanted maybe psychologically this will
affect both we need to maybe kind of
think that he's playing against himself
you know one of the tactics when you
play a chess match of this magnitude but
the reason why Knight to f4 is so
powerful because if you go night the
before with the same idea of you know
organizing some some play against the d5
pawn then rook to h6 is coming and now
after you capture a queen captures on d5
now Queen to h4 and white is lost there
is no defense against twin captors on h2
you could defend this with h3 but after
Bishop captures is the game over of
course you could you could play g3 and
then rock to g6 white white will lose
this game very quickly if you capture of
course then there is no defense against
both of these threats but after Knight
to e4 this move by Tao botanique plays
Knight to f4 and this move is so
excellent because this this prevents the
same idea but it's interesting how it
prevents it here at all continued rook
to e5 but it's very interesting what
happens if you continue with the same
idea as I've shown you if the knight
came to be for now on rook h6 white
indeed can capture this pawn and after
Queen to h4 now h3 defends the position
as now the night from f4 is also
guarding the h3 pawn but here comes the
interesting part what happens if black
plays g5 simply kicking away this night
and then threatening to capture on h3
this is where the where the fun begins
and this is a this is what what when he
had to see to even even play Knight to
f4 here but when it could have become to
h5 and Bishop to h5 pretty much seals
the deal for white here you don't really
have anything to play with black white
is threatening to capture on f7 so what
do you do here if you capture the bishop
would rook captures on h5 then Knight
captures you're not gonna be able to
capture with the Queen because queen
captures on e4
I mean with the idea that if rook
captures the knight captures and then if
you capture with Queen captures on h5
first you get
Knight to c7 and then after this rook
moves then you will grab the night here
but but after this Bishop to h5 move the
strongest idea is Bishop to Bishop to e6
and after Bishop to e6 this is what you
have to find Knight captures pawn
captures and now a beautiful move Bishop
to f7 check and Bishop to f7 check wins
the game for white if you if you don't
capture the bishop for example if you
play King to a faith then Queen to d8
threatening Queen captures rook on e8
with check Knight to f6 defending the
rook and attacking the Queen Queen c7
and now your rook is attacked and also
your knight is attacked on a5 so you
have to give up the exchange Knight to
c6 Bishop captures Knight captures then
after Queen capture some b7 White is in
a completely winning position here but
an interesting thing after Bishop
captures and after Bishop to f7 check
it's interesting what happens when King
captures on f7 it seems like now white
really doesn't have a move but he
actually does and it's quite an
excellent move the idea is Knight
captures on e4 white simply takes back
the piece and now you see that if Queen
captures now comes Knight to d6 about
unique checks the King forms the Queen
and after this this is all done you can
see that both when he could be up up a
pawn and in a much better position he
would have much better pawn structure
it's a pretty much winning end game for
botanique so this is why it's definitely
my favorite move this Knight to f4 by
Botvinnik
and this is something this all botany
had to see all of this to play this move
so it's quite quite you know quite a guy
rook to e5 by Tao now defending the d5
pawn and now preparing to bring this
rook into the attack we have looked the
c1 with some nasty ideas which but
you'll see what I mean by this top plays
rook to h6 and now we have night the d4
instead of night the d4 also Knight
captures on d5 was possible with the
idea now both will be threatening rook
captures on c8 you would have to capture
than Knight to e7 check good
an idea if this rock ever moves so a lot
of ideas here but black would simply
block all of this with Knight to c6 and
then after Knight to f4 Queen to h4 it's
it's a it's not not opposition you wanna
play against the top I mean the position
could be very well equal but if you're
playing this against all the definitely
black has the advantage here
so after rook to h6 night the d4 by
botanic not not immediately going for
the d5 pawn we have Knight to c6 and now
now g3 but when I thought about playing
f3f3f3 is an interesting move but he
decided not to do it after after this G
to remove we have g5 night to d3
attacking the rook rook moves and now
Bishop to g4 again a totally totally a
botanic move exchanging even more
material and after Bishop captures Queen
captures it's really hard to see how
tall would continue this attack here
knife capture son before was played eke
after sandy 4 and Queen to f6 talha tal
says that here he definitely did
consider a move like f5 but after f5
white can simply capture the F pawn and
have to rook to a fate Queen to g4
there's really no way to continue this
attack would Black Knight the d2 will be
met with rook to c8 this is the problem
Queen captures and now Queen captures a
hand g5 this is with check King moves
Queen captures on d2 not grabbing the
rook by grabbing the night and d2 also
you're rockin H six is still attacked
after we move the rook Queen to b4 and
white being up to pawns definitely has
compensation this night is coming to e5
which will be an excellent square white
is white is better here so after each
capture son before tall decides to go to
night Queen to f6 Knight to e5 we have
night to d2 now attacking the rook on f1
and here rook F to d1 also possible for
Botvinnik was f4 f4 with the idea that
if Knight captures rook captures
it's very hard to find a move here for
black as f captor Sanjeev I will be a
threat but after black plays rope to g6
then it's it's it's a perfectly fine
position with F captors and g5 Queen
captures and Queen to f3 pressuring that
f7 pawn this rope can't really move you
would have to you would have to give it
up so a very interesting a very
interesting position but the reason what
eunuch didn't go for f4 is because he
still wants to win this game he doesn't
want to draw so rook have to be one
keeping all of his options open
we have rook captures on e5 and now rook
captures and b2 again if botany plays D
characters on e5 then comes a knight to
f3 check this is basically tau tal would
be forced to force the draw here because
King to f1 now Queen to a6 check King to
g2 now rook captures on h2 check King
captures on f3 and now Queen to eight
recheck capturing the pawn kinky - Queen
- a - check and now you have to go up
the board reacting to d3 and then the
Queen will simply continue checking you
and it will be a perpetual and if you
block with the rook then that would even
win the game after winning all of these
rocks then power would be up three
points completely winning Queen and pawn
in game so after rook captures on a5
look after sandy - but eunuch still
wants to go for a win rook to e4 Quintus
e8 check and this this was probably were
were Botvinnik
kind of missed it because here in this
move Botvinnik offered a draw and he
offered the draw and then he played
Queen to c8
while he offered the draw and the tile
didn't tell like this move here tau
declined the draw because he said that
if what when he played the Queen to d7
that he would in fact
accept a draw now this does come with
the threat of clink after some b7 Queen
captures on d5 is a threat and here he
would accept a draw but since what when
he played Queen to c8 this comes with
check kind of forcefully winning the b7
pawn here cut all declined it because he
has an idea here King to g7 now Queen
captures on b7 and we
to e6 with the threat of rook to e1 here
botanique defense with rook to f1 he
doesn't allow this check but a more
precise moment was queen to be - with
the idea that after an exchange happens
and he won this Rokon d2 is protected by
the queen but okay rook to f1 by botanic
rook to e1 and now Queen to b5 guarding
that f1 square
Queen to h3 and now f3 making room for
the other rook to come to the F file
Queen back to e6 and now rook comes to
f2 rook to f6 and now rook captures any
one Queen captures and the King to g2 g
for Queen to d3 both players are in in
some time trouble here as this is more
37 so three more moves have to be made
before reaching time control h5 by tau
rook to f1 Queen 26 F captures on g4
rook to f1 and King captures an f1 so
King captors on f1 was moved for T and
here H captures on g4 by tau this is
move 44 tall so time control has been
reached and here they have to adjourn
the game so Botvinnik has has to decide
which move he will he will save for
tomorrow so they will be able to analyze
that you know overnight and here the
game was adjourned and tile thought that
talent complaints both thought that King
to g2 was definitely the strongest move
which would give black the hardest time
playing the same game and they spent the
entire night analyzing King to g2
tomorrow when they finally got to the
game they saw that bot make plays the
move pawn to a4 and the pawn to a4 isn't
so strong tall immediately played Queen
to b6 and he will be able to pick up
this pawn now King to f2 now Queen to b4
and King to e3 the thing is you don't
really gain anything by Queen to D 1 you
can defend both of these points with the
Queen but you can't really make any
progress here the Queen can never move
from d1 because you'll simply grab
either either a pawn or the D pawn and
you can never pull the pawn so does
really doesn't really make
to keep an eye on it so instead
botanique tries a came to e3 we have
Queen captures and now King to f4 Queen
to a - now Quinn to e3 Queen captures
Queen Chuck's King moves and now Quinta
d6 check King moves and now Queen
captures on d5 so the material is equal
but Botvinnik does have the past D pawn
if you can get some somehow with the
king up the board and stop the checks
from tile this could be very well
winning going to have to check King
captures now comes f5 check King King to
g5 and now Queen captures on g3 King
captures on f5 and now Queen to g6 check
King to f4 and now Queen to f6 check so
what eunuch does have a past D pawn but
it's very questionable if if he can
actually do something about this King to
e3
knocking to a fate acting to d3 Queen to
f1 check King to e4 and queen to g2
check that says that these checks are
kind of pointless if he simply placed
team to e7 it's perfectly fine for black
and the black can no longer gain
opposition as this King would be too
close King to e5 now Queen checks and g5
King e6 Queen e7 check King to f5
and here tile finds the only move that
pretty much saves the game for black if
if you try here something like Queen to
h7 you get into a5 Queen to h5 check
King to d6 and after Queen to H to check
into Queen to e5 and now white will
white will win this game as there are no
more there are no more checks here and
this pawn is coming up the board white
will be able to win this game so after
King to a5 Queen to c7 and now black a
white really doesn't wait have a way of
continuing this Queen 288 check and this
is a bot eunuchs last trick in the game
botany you have to see this position see
this position and then Botanic plays
Queen to a eight botanique is trying to
get taught to play Queen to f6 to f7
then he will repeat Queen to d5 and
after Queen to King to f8 it will be the
same position
before Botvinnik played Queen to a check
but now it's but now it would be both
eunuchs move so he kind of would have a
triangulated the position
so after this Queen to eight I think to
e7 not King 12:7 Queen to b4 check-in to
d8 Queen to h4 checked in to c8 going to
HEA check King to b7 Queen to e5
offering a trade of Queens now Queen
checks King to e4 Queen checks Queen
blocks now Queen to d5 quinta d6 and now
there is no way to kick the black Queen
off of off of the d6 square Queen to f7
check doesn't really give you anything
if you exchange Queens by playing Queen
35 because black was simply ignore it of
course not capturing he will simply play
King c7 and after Queen c5 check King d7
you know King Queen captures team
captures you can never win this as White
will never be able to gain opposition on
the black king so after Queen to d6
Queen to f7 check we have King to see it
Queen to a5 check came to the 8th Queen
to a5 check in moves d5 now King to d7
Queen to a7 check King to d8 Queen to
8th King to d7 King to f5 and after King
to e7
this is move 72 in this position they
finally agreed to a draw
so after towel winning game 11 he still
two points in the lead and now they drew
game 12 and game 13 is a relatively
short game so I might even show that one
today well we'll see but s tomorrow is
the start of the Greinke chess classic
I'll probably I'll probably do a nice
preview of the of the Cross in Caruana
one of the games but we'll see so yeah I
would like to thank me to Niraj and make
me talk in a tunnel ah hurry
although Galvin and hosted by the end
toast for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here both of them will be from
the top what unique series you can check
out being 11 in game 10 if you haven't
and also in the description below there
will be a link to the entire playlist if
you want to
get out so yeah that's it thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon